next up we're gonna be talking about the
halo 5 launch trailer that we saw
recently we learned a lot of halo news
recently i'm joined on the couch by Mike
McCarty and Rob handlery now you guys
are some of the biggest Halo fans we
have in the office and I'm sure you guys
have seen the trailer multiple times
what we saw a little bit of new stuff a
little bit of the old stuff what was new
in this trailer we talked about this
morning just like different enemy types
that we weren't completely familiar with
we were wondering what those guys in the
white were but I think where I start
talking about the Prometheans right
right so who's like this Promethean
character I found out his name is called
the warden or he's a class of Promethean
having played war zone game-mode couple
times when a few times at e3 those are
some of the guys the AI elements of the
mode where you essentially you know you
team up with hey so-and-so let's go out
here and basically stop over this AI
boss like figure to you know break up
points routine so this Promethean guys I
was looking I was watching the trailer
as well they looked very destiny like a
those the characters you're talking
about the kind of destiny yes but in
Halo 3 for 3 s defense Prometheans
started in Halo 4 so it's more destiny
is stealing Ben that originals yeah so
bungees just cherry-picking from
everyone I don't know that's the correct
use the word cherry-picking but yeah
this is that you know that digitally
reconstructed people they kind of look
like elites as if they got rights but
Didact you know made them into
Prometheans just through that process I
forget was called but yeah and then the
entire trailer was set to amuse his
knights of cydonia which is a really
gold song and a lot of people are saying
they don't want that song near halo or a
video game in general but tell me you
don't watch this trailer and just get
amped as hell for this they went
especially when OT mo Cyrus is just
jumping down the hill shot getting
people in the face and then it's gotta
lay down and lay down yeah i know this
is great it kicks in like right here and
then oh man it's I'm amped it was it was
good well one thing we have not gotten a
lot from this trailer we haven't learned
a lot in general but we're still getting
these little hints is where this story
is going you see master chief when we
get this that there is some kind of
conflict with Locke and there's the
other halo teams
and Mike you are really into halo lawyer
you've read a lot of these apps like you
know the two back in the front ends got
like rom I think you were saying that
you've played a lot of Halo games but
maybe not to the extent yeah I'm the
books I've played them all uh-huh and I
and I felt like I knew the story pretty
well and this game was one of the first
times were spun me around a lil bit and
it's like wait who's Osiris team i get i
know buck was from ODST correct yeah
like certain characters I recognize but
you know who is this team that master
chief has and that pertains to the lore
and the books you know I I mean I looked
it up i had to do my little wiki
research obviously but like you know you
find out that that this team is there
look there the original spartan tues the
they grew up and trained with Master
Chief and that's pretty cool i mean i
hope i hope to play the game and they
tap on a lot of that you know a
backstory yeah you can go into more I'm
sure Mike oh yeah you're right there
these are pretty much the last few
Spartan tues you know in the first in
halo combat evolved the first game you
think that Master Chief is the last one
and then you find out that if when you
you know after halo reach you find out a
few of them survived but halo the fall
of reach Eric Nilan wrote it is just a
prequel to the first halo and that's
these are some of the original people
even before they got the muscle
augmentation so they can wear the suit
because of a normal human where's that
suit the reflex will be so fast we'll
break a bone and then react to that
break another bone just kind of kill
yourself really fast it's gruesome in
the book but they need to get these
muscle augmentations and a lot of them
die off from that but i think it's Fred
Linda and Kelly they're each kind of
specialist Fred or is it Sam no your
head right ok so fred is just the big
like strong one and you know Linda and
Kelly kind of fill out the fast and
sniper rolls right and so it's kind of
this squad based combat anthony wong go
was a lead designer on republic commando
the star wars game and now he's working
on halo 5 which kind of from what I play
to the campaign it's kind of very much
this not a ton of tactics but you can
tell your teammates were at a fire if
you're not playing co-op and you can
tell them you know regroup on me and you
can kind of take these branching paths
and I think that's kind of cool that
it's fitting into this narrative because
it seems like it's gonna be a frantic
narrative you know traditionally in
halos your
this alien world or just this ring world
trying to figure things out there's this
mystery that's propelling you forward
even halo 4 when you're on Requiem but
now this just seems like it's
straightforward just team Osiris [ __ ]
chasing after the chief and the chief
you have no idea like whether he's good
or bad anymore because I won't spoil the
ending of halo 4 I don't know how many
people finished it but something happens
the end the halo 4 that's going to mess
with his head so now he's kind of from
what I played your kind of your messed
up and then you can see that and you see
an 343 is trying to push that so I'm
interested to see the dynamic between
blue team and Osiris as they're chasing
chief well if they need different teams
and it sounds like they're trying to
solve a mystery they probably should
call in one maybe Fred Velma and Shaggy
oh my god haha I'm sorry I then the
Ghostbusters go ahead and start wrecking
people to what is suggested but yeah you
know there was one trailer where I saw
or was it was uh the blue team in like a
pelican going somewhere and chiefs just
like flying and like the other figure
back there like dude she's kind of
losing his mind yes we talked what's
going on to Scott he's you know he's
just gonna I don't like it yeah that's
what's funny because these are the
people that he grew up with a Spartan to
program is really messed up Catherine
Halsey his character would come in
abduct these kids who were showing signs
of promise clone them give the clones to
the parents she literally took right on
from a playground yeah I'm not kidding
she went to a playground took him put
his clone on the playground that cloning
back to the parents they have no idea
that the actual John's been missing
hello father he went through like
Spartan sugar that's me time are you
okay yes you seem a little off Ashley
just said no to it I don't know okay
grow so anyway so it's these are the
people that he's closest with his whole
life aside from you know Cortana and
it's interesting to see them they come
up in like put their hands back like
dude you all right are you sure and then
he's like [ __ ] you were going and
everybody's just the entire human race
is kind of like this guy's losing his
mind and we should probably do something
to stop him now and we'll learn a lot
more about the story as it goes along of
course but we did learn some more about
how the game itself will will shake out
now there's not going to be any big team
battle but they're taking that out of
the
multiplayer playlist for a reason right
I think the idea is that when
multiplayer kicks off they they want
people to really dive into the new ones
right war zone and arena you know all
the dlc for halo 5 will be free so it's
like you don't have to stress about that
I think I recalled big team battles and
more of the you know maybe oddball are
the ones that I didn't see on the list
will come out down the road toward the
end of the year so they're comin you
know and and personally war zone was so
much fun i I'm really excited for that
one mmhmm yeah I think it could be the
one to fill the gap left by a big team
battle right but the thing that I think
maybe people are more concerned about in
which bungee that are ya bungee the
developer has had to comment 343 not
bungee the people well those are once we
told the Prometheans 343 has commented
on micro transactions and I think that
can always be kind of a sword that can
be a very big sticking point and in this
there is going to be a micro transaction
element where if you want to get these
requisition packs the Rex mm-hmm you can
either use in-game currency or you can
spend real world money how do you guys
feel about that I feel alright with what
I mean and this was the the looming
question was what's the conversion how
much will it cost to get Rex and so we
looked it up just before and you know
it's well he releases a couple weeks ago
I think again the price range was 2000
rec points for it was a how much four
dollars three dollars which basically
correlates to two games two 30-minute
matches of war zone that's that's
nothing to me I mean that's I'm okay
with that yeah it seems like you're
getting a fair amount of rewards from
just playing yeah it doesn't I just
inherently don't love micro transactions
in a game that's already sixty dollars
but i think this doesn't seem awful it
seems like you're getting rewarded for
the amount of time you play and it
doesn't seem like the money will speed
like push you past people in too big of
a way i think it still will have a
balance between you're gonna play a lot
of our game we're going to reward you
for it if you want to pay go for it go
for it if you want it i think i think of
it as you know you have these three
different types of rec cards you have
your cosmetics assassinations those are
permanent just says unlocking certain
weapons vehicles are kind of the burn
cards you know use a mantis late game
but it comes down to you can only if you
were really going to get one of these
items thing like a mantis and you're
gonna pay the three dollars whatever is
to get couple these guys you still have
to do get to play well in order to
unlock it on the battlefield so it's
there's still a there's still a bit like
a roadblock that's basically stopping
people from just you know you know
buying tons amount of cards and using
whenever they want you can you have to
be able to perform well in the war zone
field in order to pull them out so I'm
okay with that yeah it doesn't seem like
it's kind of a pay to win situation I
mean maybe we'll find out it is when we
play the game or but like you said I'd
really don't think that's the case at
all from what like the info they've
given us it doesn't seem like that's the
case right and I do wonder also you know
for the arena mode you're paid like your
burn cards aren't there so the pay to
win aspect is completely and I removed I
wonder if that's even going to be like
an option for like custom modes maybe
you can like turn off any kind of like
aspects correlating to that you know I
mean for like SWAT maybe you can just
get like down down and gritty and just
like have you know just the basic power
weapons on the map and that's it yeah so
we'll see I don't know well so my last
question talking about the story and you
know since we have someone who is so
knowledgeable of all the intricacies of
halo they've made a big deal of being
either team Master Chief team lock where
do you think the story is going what is
your wild fan theory for how this is
actually going to play out since right
now we don't have the game we don't know
what's going to happen what what do you
think is gonna be ooh personally I would
love to see chief just lose his mind and
just be batshit crazy by the end and
then lock has to come in and then chief
still kills him and then you know halo 6
chief is just a lunatic so right it's a
it's a trilogy part I did hear that like
this the rumor or like not removed the
the facts are that a lot of questions
are going to be laid out then more
answered so yeah there's going to be
there's me probably some crazy
cliffhanger at the end of this just like
there was a halo 2
it's just like oh god I got away I gotta
wait three to two more years for the
next one like uh yeah to finish what
size oh yeah him on the the forerunner
great worship Martha chief what you do
it on that it's like finishing this for
anyone it just cuts to the music i could
see obviously to the reclaimer trilogy
and chief is the reclaimer as for all
intents and purposes as far as we're led
to believe so I and I think they're
pushing narrative ever since halo 4 i've
actually loved halo 4 story and i think
that it definitely will just leave three
open and maybe take that traditional
trilogy arc of the second one being a
really dark one and not necessarily you
know leaving the resolution open for the
third game the empire strikes back so
yeah two towers um Empire Strikes Back I
will I said I'm interested to see where
this is gonna how this is gonna pan out
Mike uh Rob thanks so much for joining
me for all of you guys at home halo 5
launches on october 27th that's coming
up really soon what do you think the
story is going to be how do you think
this is all going to pan out let us know
and thanks for watching